My first pitch meeting was with
an Angel investor called Owen.
And I gave the pitch of my life and
he was convinced.
I felt that he fell for me.
And in the second meeting I brought
my team members and he said,
yeah, amazing, let's do it.
And somewhere in doing
the meeting he told me Norm,
I have a feeling that you have
a feeling that I'm in your pocket.
You know what?
Let's stop it right there.
You go and get five more investors
to give the same amount of money
that I'm going to give you.
And then I'll give you my money.
What do you say about that?
And I said, what?
Really?
Why?
I thought,
I thought if we're doing this.
No, no, I want more people to
participate in this round.
And you know what?
I want you to bring in an engine
with the whole Gigi level.
And that time and
still, Gigi Levy was the most
notable engine investor in Israel.
And Gigi was like a celebrity for
me, I don't know him.
He said, yeah, go do that.
Go do that, that will be your test.
And I went from that meeting with
my team members somewhere between
humiliated to disappointed,
to what's going on?
I really thought that we're
going to start operating.
But not, so the next day I
just like this isn't fart,
how I'm going to
approach this person and
I was so
I was the hokiest of the hokies.
And I didn't know anyone.
So my best chance was just to Facebook
message this Angel [COUGH] sorry.
So my best chance was to Facebook
message this angel investor.
And this is a huge no-no.
Everybody will tell you,
this is so hood.
Don't do it.
It's so amateur, it's so unprofessional.
But I did it, and
he answered right away.
Three days later we had a meeting.
We had an amazing meeting.
And he decided to invest and
this guy became my mentor he became
one of my favorite person on Earth.
And he invested not once, not twice,
four times in my companies.
And now he's following,
he followed us to the next company.
And yes, I'm excited to talk about him.